[Music]
you've had such such an incredible
career you've done so much incredible
work and it all really started if I'm if
I'm right it really started like jump
started with taxi driver didn't it I
well you've been working before that but
taxi driver sort of was a stratospheric
launch it was a beautiful movie was the
you know the seventies and the Golden
Age of filmmaking and I guess it was
surprising that I played a prostitute
and waited
yeah very young prostitute in the film
we have a picture of you here from that
from that film and it was hard to
believe it was 40 years ago you just did
a panel with the director Martin
Scorsese and the cast is that right cast
Robert De Niro Harvey Keitel simple
shepherd Paul Schrader the writer was
there that was great what was it like
for you to be there and be talking to
these people that you knew I mean you
were a kid when you knew them and now
here you are all these years later did a
lot of fun memories come back was it a
fun panel to do it was fun pal I mean
you know there's they're the same with
each other as they ever were they're
kind of a funny little dysfunctional
family and Martin Scorsese's just you
know adorable he's very giggly and he
he's sort of like a little cartoon
character and he just you know talking
really fast and his eyebrows go really
quickly he talks quickly and he gets
examiner's him it isn't animated he's
like I always think of them as one of
those little birds that lands you know
it like lands outside your window it
looks around it says like I know and
then it takes off yes and ran Robert De
Niro is sort of the monosyllabic guy
yeah still not much to say yeah and sort
of like the little brother who's always
you know pulling pranks and saying look
at me
yeah so they've essentially not changed
you know it's funny the the subject
matter at the time was so heavy that you
sense when you were making that film I
read this once that you thought that
maybe De Niro and Scorsese were they
didn't quite know how to behave around
you because you're a kid they're making
this very dark heavy film that ends up
being one of the great seminal films of
the 70s especially when I had to unzip
his fly and things like that they were a
little uncomfortable they were
uncomfortable about that so how did they
handle their disco miss Diggle
they just giggled uncontrollably mostly
Scorsese giggled he would try to give me
a direction and then he would just burst
into laughter and then which of course
is horribly
appropriate you know it's like it's
probably don't that's helping you in
that situation or helping that these
adults were supposed to be in charge or
just giggling the whole time yeah Robert
Hiro you took it on and I think he took
on the being the bridge between Scorsese
and myself and he would you know try to
wipe the smile off his face and then ask
me to do things but I had a lot of
movies at that point I've made probably
more movies than De Niro and Scorsese
that's true that's true so you were
seasoned what was your attitude then
when they were acting all nervous and
we've got to ask this kid to do this
thing that's strange or really out there
on the edge and we don't know how to do
it your attitude was this is my job I've
been doing my whole life I don't know
really know why they were you know
getting all nutty about it right for me
that what I remember of taxi driver was
a great summer in New York but I kept
going to the theater and going hansom
cabs and you know getting my picture
taken at Rockefeller Center and things
like that and then during the day or at
night actually I'd go off and put the
hot pants on and walk around streets
that's just what I do when I go to New
York
you